we're so driven by bigotry and hate that
we attack our fellow citizens as
traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
god help us yeah god help us it's
amazing a weasel can produce crocodile
tears
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's time it is time once again
for everything
is racist
it's true first up remember the chicago
mayor who looks like she hasn't slept
since 1972.
i can't blame her in that city the
constant gunfire will keep
anyone up at night lori lightfoot
racist continues to defend her decision
to only speak
with non-white reporters you know
because that's what racists do
i would absolutely do it again i'm
unapologetic
about it because it spurred a very
important conversation a conversation
that needed to happen that should have
happened long time ago
you know she's right her racist behavior
spurred a very important conversation
about how racist she is i love that
logic now watch
me start a dialogue on arson with these
oil-soaked rags and a bic lighter
sure people died but look how much we've
learned about the importance of smoke
alarms
but it makes perfect sense coming from a
leftist because to them talk is more
important
than action and lightfoot much prefers
the race conversation over the crime one
she's the andrew cuomo of chicago
only her bodies aren't piling up in
nursing homes they're piling up in the
streets
and they're brown and they're black and
they're young
imagine if she were white people would
start asking questions like is this
deliberate
but dare criticize her over her record
you know what she's going to say
mayor in recent months there have been
questions raised about your
your temperament and your reaction to
criticism
tribune editorial use the term irascible
uh how much of this do you think might
have to do with the fact that you're a
woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it women and people of color
are always held to a different standard
i understand that i've known that my
whole life
why isn't it 100 her answers are as
predictable as cats hangovers
but according to lightfoot pointing out
her record is racist
then again to her pointing out that she
has food on her face is racist
takes a special person presiding over
mass murder to think that they're the
victim
she expects you to bleed to death on the
pavement grateful
your mayor is not some old white guy but
you know what else is racist
comedy according to racist author of
white fragility
robin deangelo
so comedy is um
i think it's an excuse to get to be
racist right like
irony and i think tv shows like family
guy and
um south park and maybe a little bit the
simpsons right
allowed white people to be racist
self-consciously
right like i know i'm being racist and
therefore
it doesn't count and it's okay who
better to tell us what's funny than
someone who has stage four cancer of the
funny bone
this grifter wouldn't know funny if you
gave her the f-u-n-n
on wheel of fortune
so funny white people are racist cool
and writing a book
generalizing about white people isn't
and what's more fragile than someone who
can't take a joke
think about it the loudest voices
shouting about racial inequality
are often weak need virtue signaling
caucasians
yet what have they done to correct the
injustice and the inequality
besides putting a blm sign in their
front yard and a rainbow coexist bumper
sticker on their tesla
isn't it time they resign their jobs to
make room
and correct this injustice every lily
white leftist in a comfy editorial
position at a magazine or a tv show or
college
it's time to move on and fix your
privilege anna wintour
say hello to vanessa bush jimmy kimmel
say hello to chris tucker
paul krugman say hello to coleman hughes
and chris cuomo
say hello to candace owens i wonder what
the angry black male has to say
[Music]
i knew i'd be here for you today i'm
ready today
all right all right kids let me break
this down for you
i got a yellow apple hi
and i got a green apple hi
what you don't talk to yellow apples
because they're yellow
oh rice's apple
oh my gosh again for being racist
[Music]
he should have known better right oh i
want to talk to you unless you yellow
you don't um
you should have known better racist ass
apple
still good though that's up
[Applause]
nicely done so if you're white and find
race behind everything it's time to put
your money where your motor mouth is
get out if you're you know you're big on
a 15
minimum wage so give it a try how great
would it be to have bright stelter say
to you you want to supersize that just
check your fries before you leave
but if you don't quit then clearly
you're the racist thinking you deserve
that job
over a person of color so until all
white leftists resign their jobs we must
all hold them accountable either step up
or shut up
let's start by demanding that every
white person at cnn resign immediately
but then again with their ratings who's
gonna notice
let's welcome tonight's guests
there's no co-pay to see her tonight
fox news medical doctor jeannette
ness way that's what guess what
he's got a face for comedy and the looks
of a starbucks barista
westernrazer.com spokesman david angelo
yeah once you get to know her
she's even worse fox news contributor
cat tim
and if he says he's so hungry he could
eat a horse
hide your horse my massive sidekick and
joseph enough said on fox station tyrus
since the topic is comedy david i want
to go to you
first as a racist comedian
do you think comedians are all racist
uh no i don't i do think it is funny
though that the
de facto expert on racism in america
right now is this white woman
it's like guys we need to elevate the
voices of you know people of color and
all this stuff and then she just comes
in like hey i got i'll handle these
questions
let me take the let me take the lead on
this all right yeah
i would love to know how many black
people live within five miles of robin
d'angelo's house
can we get a survey on that yeah
actually i actually have the facts here
dave and i'm glad you asked there's
nothing
there's no way yeah it's true she's like
the what you call the white racist
whisperer
right she's like i know what they're
thinking that's what that's how she got
famous yeah i mean a lot of them they do
it
they i think they have latent racist
feelings and they do this as like
overcompensation or something but you
know here's the thing as annoying as she
is i still don't want
i still do always try to like better
myself so if there's like things like
you know i
i do really sincerely am like is there
things i can do
but she's so obnoxious and they go so
over the top i think it actually hurts
a lot of the reflection normal people
would have because it's so much all the
time there might be
yeah there might be some there might be
something there
that we everybody could do better but
when you become when the person becomes
a parody it's like you can't
she is funnier than family guy her book
is better than the simpsons
i mean it's let's she is absolutely
hysterical all right
doctor good to see you i i butchered
your i
butchered your name yes it was supposed
to be guess what nesh what yeah
and then i just lost the tea that's okay
it's a good one my sister
my mom she's like just tell them it's
jeanette guess what
neshwatt and i've had that all my life
and it's always worked so have you
thought about changing your name to
something like smith
maybe shorten it a little bit easier for
you you know we had a chat in the green
room i had a little bit of uh heartburn
and you said i should get an ekg
yes that's right that's a lot for
heartburn well if how do we know it's
heartburn a little chest pain a little
pressure a little nausea
just want to be safe we got to protect
you bro
we want to keep you healthy
what if i told you can you use one of
one of david's uh razors to shave
all the hair thank you thank you for the
ekg what
what if i thought that somebody close to
me at work might be putting ground up
glass in my oatmeal
no who could that be i would do that to
you
so you know if the united states was a
patient right and you see this constant
obsession with race and everything
what would be your prognosis as a doctor
are you worried
well i think first of all there is no
room for racism
no matter what we can't fight racism
with racism but
when it comes to comedy i mean that's it
that's what makes it a little bit edgy
and you know america needs to lighten up
a little bit that's what makes us laugh
and of course laughter is the best
medicine oh i've never heard that before
i've never heard that before you say out
of this well
okay like if you want me to i can go
back home
i was gone for a while and you were you
did miss me or i wouldn't be back
well yeah if that that missing wore off
let's be honest okay
yeah oh it took me two days you know
tyrus uh i never saw a man uh
crush an apple with his hands you
haven't
no well now you have
you know what we're seeing is whenever
these
um racist wreck notice they notice
racism
they talk really loud but they say
absolutely nothing
when life was asked a question like why
did you do that and i'm unapologetic
because it started a conversation about
a conversation that needed to happen
please follow-up question again i didn't
go to journalist school what's the
conversation well the conversations is a
conversation about extensive
conversations
so we're talking about you can't ask me
that racist race being
racist is meaningless now racist is a
new term for somebody you don't like
yeah it has nothing to do with skin
color it's just i
what you disagree with me racist and if
it's it's like white on white racist
crime now it's like
everybody's a racist so if everyone's a
racist nobody's really a racist
right so you know that's good for david
yes the only thing was you can't and you
can't be a little bit racist
yeah family guy racist simpsons they're
a little bit racist you're either
are you all in or are you all out you
don't wear half a clan mask
you know what i'm saying like you you
know it's just ridiculous the fact that
we
they play on this because the reason why
they can't talk about it is because they
have no experience with it
and that's a beautiful thing is when
people have to make up
about what's racist because they haven't
experienced it
or seen it so of course you got to make
it up because if you can talk about it
you can talk about racist moments
yeah but racist just like anything else
is the individual sport it is not the
country anymore
that's a very good point cat he raises
this
fine young man over here raising some
interest the point that everybody says
they're unapologetic that as if that's a
good thing
but maybe you should apologize yeah
sometimes right and it's just
the idea of not being afraid to question
things i mean thinking about the idea
when it comes to comedy that intention
doesn't matter and she's saying okay
like you know punching up
don't punch down it's like how about a
more important question is is this
supposed to be a punch
are you trying to make people laugh i
think that is a very
important distinction because intention
matters
in everything else in life it matters
when a person
kills another person are you saying that
the one thing that's so serious that
intention can't matter is
jokes i don't buy it this is a this is
probably one of the most
important points you have ever made oh
thank you no it because
people now these these uh anti-racist uh
activists say intention doesn't matter
when they preface things it's like
it's like when you when you were when
you're teaching let's say is it huck
finn
and it's got the racial slur and if you
if you're the teacher and you bring it
up you will lose your job
because intention doesn't matter right
right
so like if tyrus if you you know instead
of the glass and the coffee seems
premeditated but if he drives your
car accidentally hits you then he's
that's manslaughter
really interesting yeah there you go
yeah
all right it's a lever though up next
violent criminals attack but liberal
laws make it hard
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else